[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia del joven 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación el sumario de
algunos de los temas que vamos a
desarrollar en este programa
brasil el epicentro mundial de la
pandemia desarrolló su propia vacuna
contra el cob y 19 el instituto butantán
anunció que ha pedido la autorización a
las autoridades sanitarias de este país
para comenzar la fase 1 de pruebas en
personas 40.000 dosis serán elaboradas
esta buena noticia contrasta con las
cifras que se están viendo en ese país
más de 300.000 personas han fallecido a
lo largo de la semana y hubo también
récords de 100.000 personas contagiadas
en un espacio de 24 horas el
confinamiento y las restricciones
comienzan a la par de la semana santa
tenemos los detalles desde la ciudad de
río de janeiro hablaremos también de la
contradicción que está viviendo chile el
país líder en la vacunación en la región
de américa latina pero que superó su
récord histórico de contagios desde el
inicio de la emergencia sanitaria más de
7000 nuevos casos en solamente 24 horas
buena parte del país va a regresar a un
confinamiento riguroso debido a esta
segunda ola que se está mostrando mucho
más agresiva que la anterior también en
minutos daremos un vistazo a cómo está
la situación
país suramericano y hablaremos de eeuu
que hizo frente esta semana a
situaciones insólitas como la llegada
masiva de turistas a la ciudad de miami
con motivo del receso de primavera las
autoridades locales tuvieron que
decretar el toque de queda vamos a ver
cómo está avanzando la situación en esa
ciudad del estado de florida esto
mientras el país contabiliza 300 o mejor
30 millones de casos confirmados de kobe
19 el presidente yo vaivén también dobló
su apuesta y espera inmunizar a 200
millones de personas en sus primeros 100
días de mandato veremos si esto es
factible si se puede lograr vamos a
comenzar entonces directamente en brasil
vamos a profundizar allí la situación
que se está viviendo en este país
suramericano sigue siendo crítica la
situación allí en este país para algunos
científicos analistas es el ejemplo
claro de todo lo que podría salir mal en
la pandemia en este caso del coronavirus
con más de 100 mil casos nuevos
registrados en solamente 24 horas
registrados a lo largo de esta semana
allí los hospitales están llenos el
confín
y una vacunación dispara hacen que
brasil sea un motivo de preocupación
para la región sobre todo para países
como uruguay paraguay bolivia que tienen
ciudades fronterizas que en muchos casos
comparten infraestructura y que hacen
parte de una sola zona urbana demos un
vistazo a cómo están las cifras allí
para el cierre de esta semana brasil
contabiliza más de 12 millones 320 mil
casos confirmados unos 10 millones 808
mil 499 personas se han recuperado ya
del cob y 19 en ese país se han
fallecido 303 mil 462 personas esto
mientras que la vacunación avanza ya
16.56 millones de personas están ya
vacunadas
y la buena noticia llega desde el
instituto butantán que anunció que su
proyecto de una vacuna contra el cob y
19 entró en la fase 1 ya solicitaron la
autorización para que sea aprobada en
humanos brasil y cuba serían entonces
los primeros países en américa latina'
en desarrollar su vacuna propia contra
el cubil 19 así está la situación en
este país veamos
por fuera parece un día tranquilo pero
un piso más arriba se trabaja contra el
reloj para conseguir plazas en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos estamos
gestionando nuevas camas para tener la
demanda vinicius trabaja de sol a sol
para salvar vidas
río de janeiro suma 20.000 muertos de
los 300.000 registrados en todo el país
en las últimas dos semanas la media de
fallecidos creció un 67 por ciento
este equipo hace la captación de plazas
identifica las camas vacías en nuestra
red y las pone a disposición para los
médicos reguladores
lo que nos preocupa desde el inicio de
la pandemia es que el aumento de casos
se ha abrupto se ha todo a la vez
desde esta central los enfermos más
graves son enviados a hospitales como
este que es una referencia en la región
aquí los pacientes intubados son cada
vez más jóvenes
había muchas camas vacías que se han
llenado en las últimas dos semanas lo
que acontece muchas veces es que el
paciente no consigue llegar hasta
nosotros por una cuestión de
vulnerabilidad familiar o social tener
habilidades sociales no conseguir
ingenieros en ellos no consiguen tener
acceso a los servicios sanitarios
entonces no tenemos la noción real de
los casos que están aconteciendo porque
muchos de ellos ni conseguimos tratarlos
muchos pueden morir antes en sus casas
otra preocupación es la posible falta de
oxígeno
esta empresa abastece los principales
hospitales públicos y privados de río
están en contacto permanente con las
autoridades sanitarias para poder
satisfacer una demanda que crece cada
día
espero que no haya un colapso en río
pero si lo hay
vamos a traer oxígeno desde otras
ciudades que están mejor para darnos
este apoyo nos da soporte que el viernes
rio de janeiro empieza un lock down de
10 días para intentar contener el avance
de la pandemia para ello es necesario
que los ciudadanos colaboren y que las
playas queden así desiertas vamos a
profundizar en la situación de este país
suramericano está con nosotros valeria
saccone la corresponsal de france 24 en
la ciudad de río de janeiro hola valeria
gracias por acompañarnos nuevamente en
el programa y quiero que comencemos por
las cifras más de 300.000 personas
fallecidas 100.000 personas contagiadas
en solamente 24 horas
o lo que está pasando allí todos
pensábamos que ya habíamos llegado a la
peor de la situación que se podía ver en
brasil pero esto cada vez demuestra que
se agrava más
brasil está lejos de superar el peor
momento de la pandemia esta semana se
contabilizaron los 300.000 muertos y
además hubo días de picos con más de
3000 muertos en 24 horas sin embargo los
epidemiólogos advierten de que si se
sigue con este ritmo de contagio se
puede llegar a más de 5000 muertos
diarios una novedad en esta segunda ola
que está haciendo es causada
mayoritariamente por la variante
brasileña es que los jóvenes están
siendo muy afectados en el estado de san
paulo se han duplicado el número de
contagios entre los jóvenes de 15 y 29
años y en esta misma franja de edad las
hospitalizaciones en tan solo un mes han
pasado del 5 al 12 5 por ciento
además los relatos de los médicos son
terribles advierten de que se están
acabando los medicamentos para
incubación en algunos casos los médicos
a falta de relajante muscular y de
analgésico están usando medicamentos que
dan somnolencia como antipsicóticos
alérgicos hay que recordar que el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro no se preparó
para comprar estos medicamentos
necesarios para la intubación no tuvo la
visión de que la pandemia podría
empeorar y en agosto prohibió la compra
de más medicamentos los médicos dicen
que los hospitales parecen escenarios de
guerra
valeria precisamente el presidente
bolsonaro ha sido muy criticado por los
mismos brasileños y por la comunidad
internacional pero tal parece que está
cambiando un poco la estrategia ya lo
vemos en público utilizando mascarilla
hablando de la vacunación hasta creó un
comité para luchar precisamente contra
la pandemia ya incluso un año después de
haber empezado allí en este país
jair bolsonaro ha cambiado de actitud en
los actos públicos ya usa mascarillas y
además defiende abiertamente la
vacunación algo que no hacía hace tan
solo pocas semanas en un discurso
televisado a esta semana permite a los
brasileños que antes de que acabe el año
todos estarán vacunados y que están
trabajando para proporcionar 500
millones de dosis de vacunas sin embargo
sigue atacando el lock down defendiendo
la economía y defendiendo el llamado
tratamiento precoz es decir medicamentos
cuya eficacia no ha sido comprobada
científicamente como la cloroquina o la
invertida que es un ver mismo además
esta semana supimos que algunos
pacientes que hicieron un uso prolongado
de intermec tina como prevención contra
el kobe han sido hospitalizadas y al
menos tres pacientes van a necesitar un
trasplante de hígado
valeria muy destacado esta semana en las
últimas horas incluso ese anuncio del
instituto butantán que dijo que una de
sus vacunas ya entraría a la fase 1 es
decir la fase de pruebas en persona
sería una de las primeras vacunas hechas
en suramérica la primera en sudamérica
que más información hay al respecto
hoy el instituto butantán de sao paulo
el mismo que desarrolla la vacuna a
coronaba junto a laboratorios chinos ha
anunciado que hará la primera vacuna
100% brasileña llevar un año trabajando
en ello y ahora la van a presentar a la
agencia del medicamento si todo va bien
a partir del segundo semestre empezarán
la producción es una buena noticia en un
país que tiene 212 millones de
habitantes sabemos que las vacunas son
objetos de luchas geopolítica hacia un
país con una población tan grande va a
poder ser mucho más independiente la
lucha de la pandemia si es capaz de
producir su propia vacuna el gobernador
de san pablo cuando ya la ha anunciado
con mucho orgullo y para muchos
analistas políticos es otro gol contra
jair bolsonaro su antiguo aliado y hoy
su archienemigo político recordamos que
doria importó la vacuna desde china y
que bolsa narró le estuvo atacando
durante meses llamándola incluso de
bachín a un juego de palabras
despectivos y finalmente se tuvo que
rendir a la evidencia y comprar la
vacuna que a su vez
vividor ya había comprado en china
curiosamente hoy el ministro de ciencia
y tecnología marcos pontes ha anunciado
otra vacuna 100% brasileña que está
siendo desarrollada en la universidad de
riberao preto también en el estado de
san paulo él ha dicho que se trata de
una coincidencia que el anuncio es en el
mismo día pero que es muy bueno para
brasil
a lo largo de este año hemos notado el
incremento en esa tensión entre el
presidente bolsonaro y el gobernador
dore y el gobernador del estado de san
paulo precisamente la polarización allí
en brasil no ha dejado que los recursos
evolucionen y avancen en las
asignaciones para los diferentes estados
porque hay confrontaciones políticas
esto ha hecho que incluso poder hacer
frente a la pandemia sea muy difícil así
en brasil qué es lo que sucede
la gestión de la pandemia está creando
tensiones entre los poderes esta semana
el presidente del congreso artur lira
amenazó a bolsonaro de impeachment hay
que recordar que los primeros dos años
de legislatura se acumularon más de 60
peticiones de impeachment en la cámara
pero el antiguo presidente del congreso
no quiso seguir adelante porque decía la
popularidad del presidente es demasiado
alta sin embargo está popularidad se va
erosionando a medida que sube el número
de muertos por el coronavirus el centro
queda al soporte político al gobierno de
bolsonaro ya que hizo una primera
víctima el ministro de sanidad de
eduardo para suelo que fue destituido la
semana pasada ahora la próxima víctima
podría ser ernesto araújo el ministro de
exteriores- que representa la la
ideológica y más conservadora del
gobierno de bolsonaro araúxo ha pasado
el año de la pandemia atacando a china
una decisión no muy inteligente teniendo
en cuenta que el principio activo para
producir las vacunas en brasil tiene que
venir de este país lo ha hecho a través
de su cuenta
de 'twitter' y de hecho hay muchas voces
críticas que dicen que lo único que hace
araujo es escribir tweets e intoxicar el
ambiente diplomático en la prensa ya se
barajan nombres para substituir al
ministro de exteriores y todo apunta a
que la próxima semana será móvil y está
en brasilia
gracias valeria por este reporte desde
la ciudad de río de janeiro cambiamos de
país nos vamos hasta chile este país
rompió el récord de contagios diarios
desde el inicio de la pandemia 7.626
nuevos casos de kobe 19 después de que
el ministerio de salud identificó varios
casos de la variante brasileña británica
las autoridades se vieron obligadas a
enviar a confinamiento varias regiones
del país entre ellas entre ellas la
región metropolitana que incluye a
santiago la capital a partir del sábado
unos 7 millones de habitantes van a
quedar aislados en sus viviendas este
panorama contrasta con la rápida
vacunación que supera ya los 9.4
millones de dosis aplicadas en ese país
suramericano
así es como están las cosas en chile
pero vamos a profundizar en este tema
con patricia luna nuestra corresponsable
en la ciudad de santiago hola patricia
hablemos primero debe ser recorte que
tuvo al final de la semana chile más de
7000 personas contrajeron la enfermedad
en la cifra más alta desde el inicio de
la emergencia que dicen las autoridades
buenas tardes santiago la situación es
bastante crítica en chile- que atraviesa
el peor momento de la pandemia hasta
ahora este viernes se registraba la
cifra de contagios más altas reportada
en un solo día 7 mil 656 casos y se teme
mucho porque las unidades de cuidados
intensivos de los hospitales a lo largo
de todo el país y no sólo en la región
metropolitana como ocurrió en la primera
ola se encuentran completamente
desbordados en su capacidad a más de un
95% los trabajadores de salud vienen
advirtiendo de que es lo que va a
ocurrir cuando estas cifras se traduzcan
en un ingreso de un 15% en las unidades
un silo que podría hacer que el sistema
se encuentre completamente desbordado en
las próximas semanas
patricia está por comenzar la semana
santa en todo el mundo católico por
supuesto allí en chile también y las
autoridades han tenido que enviar un
confinamiento riguroso ya lo estábamos
mencionando varias regiones entre ellas
la región metropolitana donde está la
ciudad de santiago como se están
preparando la perspectiva del gobierno
el sentimiento de los ciudadanos volver
otra vez a estar confinados en esta
semana religiosa
a partir de este jueves 14 de los 15
millones de chilenos se encuentran bajo
una cuarentena absoluta a esto se
sumarán nuevas comunas en la región
metropolitana que estará de nuevo en su
totalidad confinada a partir de este
estado y también otras comunas en el
resto del país en total será un 84% de
los chilenos y los que se encuentren
bajo un encierro total sin embargo los
expertos cuestionan la eficacia de estas
cuarentenas que tienen poca adhesión
entre la población chilena y citan por
ejemplo según relataba el secretario
nacional del colegio médico 'josé
miguel' bernucci el caso de punta arenas
en el que después de cinco meses de
confinamiento el número de casos era
mayor al salir de la cuarentena que
antes de comenzar y en una ciudad de
150.000 habitantes se concedían 70 mil
permisos a trabajadores considerados
esenciales por eso piden al gobierno que
las cuarentenas sean estrictas que se
reduzca el número de permisos que se
conceden y que todo el mundo se adhiera
para que de verdad se produzca una
reducción de la movilidad necesaria para
bajar
la circulación del virus patricia quiero
preguntarle por la contradicción que
está viviendo este país que dicen las
autoridades porque se han esforzado
mucho para tener una altísima tasa de
vacunación son el ejemplo en la región
suramericana de hecho en buena parte del
mundo pero también como vemos el nivel
de contagio y de las personas que están
falleciendo sigue siendo muy alto y
también hay un desgaste de los equipos
de los médicos y de la misma sociedad
que dicen allí
nos encontramos precisamente cerca de un
centro de vacunación donde se sigue no
curando a las personas y lo que sabemos
es que la campaña de vacunación sigue
avanzando de forma veloz chile ya ha
vacunado con una dosis a más de 6
millones 200 mil chilenos y con dos
dosis a 32 millones de chilenos es decir
en un 18 por ciento de la población que
ya está completamente vacunada mientras
que más del 38 total de la población ya
ha recibido una primera dosis sin
embargo como ocurrió en otros países
como por ejemplo israel la vacunación
toma en tardar efecto y verse reflejada
en las cifras de contagios diarios y los
expertos también señalan que el hecho de
que se está vacunando mayoritariamente
con la vacuna china sinovac cuya
eficacia no está tan demostrada como
otras vacunas
lanza dudas sobre cuándo se va a poder
ver un reflejo de los datos de la
vacunación en los datos de contagios
diarios muchos de ellos apuntan que en
torno a abril y mayo debería empezar a
sentirse en la cifra de mortalidad y
también lo que ha señalado el ministro
enrique parís el ministro de salud es
que se empezará a sentir cuando se haya
alcanzado a los 15 millones de
diecinueve millones de chilenos
en vacunarse para conseguir la inmunidad
de rebaño algo fría que ocurriría a
finales de junio
patricia chile está haciendo frente a
este nuevo pico de contagio una nueva
ola les llaman allí han identificado
variantes británica y también brasileñas
y en el territorio chileno qué
diferencias hay entre la emergencia de
esa primera ola y la que se está
viviendo ahora en el país
pues en relación a una primera ola
entonces sabíamos mucho menos del virus
que sabemos ahora sin embargo también en
esta ocasión las personas que se
encuentran las unidades de cuidados
intensivos son población mucho más joven
por debajo de los 50 años y ellos
tienden a ocupar las camas uci también
durante más largo tiempo y por otro lado
también en un principio la carrera era
por los ventiladores mecánicos ahora
preocupa no la disponibilidad de camas
uci sino de personas que puedan atender
operar esa complejidad que implica estar
ingresado en una cama o si con un
coronavirus y esto porque los
trabajadores de salud después de un año
en el que ha estado en primera línea
luchando sin cesar contra la pandemia se
encuentran muy agotados no sólo
físicamente sino también
psicológicamente entre un 20 y 25 por
ciento de ellos según datos del colegio
médico se encuentra de licencia médica
debida a problemas relacionados con su
salud mental después de ver morir a
muchas personas durante este año eso
hace que los equipos estén muy mermados
desde el ministerio de salud se ha
buscado que tanto los estudiantes de
últimos años de medicina
como también personas jubiladas puedan
incorporarse a los hospitales y también
se ha flexibilizado para que los médicos
extranjeros puedan participar pero aún
así preocupa lo que puede suceder en las
próximas semanas también preocupa la
identificación de ciertas cepas
especialmente la brasileña y la
británica en el país que podrían tener
una mayor agresividad y desde luego
contagiarse mucho contagia del virus
mucho más rápidamente que la primera ola
pues es el panorama en chile- muchas
gracias patricia por este completo
reporte desde la ciudad de santiago la
capital chilena nos vamos ahora hasta
méxico país que se convirtió en el
tercero en el mundo en superar los
200.000 fallecidos por kobe 19 está
solamente después de eeuu y de brasil
que ya vimos cuál es el panorama en ese
otro país las autoridades sanitarias en
reportaron esta semana picos de contagio
de más de 5 mil 787 personas y la muerte
de hasta 500 84 personas en 24 horas el
temor ahora está enfocado en el posible
incremento en el número de casos de
contagio con el inicio de la semana
santa en un país que es fervientemente
católico
y con múltiples eventos para esta semana
que van a ser realizados durante la
semana santa para hacer conmemoraciones
religiosas se espera que haya un
incremento en los casos
méxico se convirtió en el tercer país en
superar la fatídica cifra de 200.000
muertes por kobe 19 en medio de la
situación el gobierno intenta aumentar
la velocidad de la vacunación en estos
días
se va
anunciando cómo vamos
y destinar más vacunas y se van a
aplicar más vacunas porque
van a participar todas
dependencias del gobierno federal
los gobiernos estatales
y se va a reforzar el plan de vacunación
la inmunización se ha ralentizado en el
país por retrasos en la entrega de
vacunas lo que ha llevado al gobierno a
señalar el acaparamiento de las dosis
por parte de los países más ricos hasta
el momento tan sólo el 0.6 por ciento de
la población ha recibido las dos dosis
del fármaco una cifra mucho menor que la
de su vecino eeuu que ha vacunado ya
totalmente al 14% de sus habitantes
algunos temen un nuevo repunte por la
relajación de la conducta social de cara
a las celebraciones de la semana santa
un cliente digo ya está llegando la
vacuna pero no es para que empecemos a
hacer fiestas reuniones y todo lo que
queramos no de acuerdo con las cifras
oficiales en méxico se han registrado
más de 2 millones 214 mil contagios y
200.000 200 muertes sin embargo el
propio ministerio de salud del país ha
asegurado que estas cifras podrían ser
mucho mayores debido a la falta de
pruebas generalizadas en la nación bueno
y comenzó habitual revisemos las cifras
de vacunación para el cierre de esta
semana pero en esta oportunidad en la
región del caribe república dominicana
supera ya las 800.000 dosis aplicadas y
se aproxima al primer millón de personas
inmunizadas puerto rico cierra esta
semana con más de 952 mil 499 dosis
aplicadas jamaica superó las 16 mil 96
dosis avanza lentamente pero va poco a
poco
barbados llega a las 62 mil 765 dosis
aplicadas hay otros países destacados en
la región como por ejemplo la trinidad y
tobago y también llama la atención de
cuba que no ha recibido ningún tipo
vacuna procedente de la comunidad
internacional precisamente vamos a ir
hasta ese país donde hay noticias
alentadoras porque se espera que esta
nación caribeña comience la campaña de
vacunación masiva a partir del mes de
junio es uno de los últimos países de la
región en hacerlo pero lo va a hacer con
vacunas propias los dos desarrollos de
vacunas cubanas ya están en la fase 3
mientras que otras tres propuestas están
muy cerca de finalizar las primeras
fases de pruebas
'cuba como ya les estaba diciendo no ha
recibido lotes de vacunas de las grandes
farmacéuticas internacionales tampoco
hace parte del mecanismo kóvacs de la o
ms para recibir algunas algunos lotes de
vacunas procedentes de la comunidad
internacional sin embargo esperan que
para el mes de agosto 6 millones de
ciudadanos ya sean inoculados con lo que
sería entonces la primera vacuna
desarrollada en américa latina' ahora
empieza entonces la competencia con
brasil
la primera vacuna latinoamericana contra
el hobbit 19 está más cerca así lo
anunció una alta funcionaria del
gobierno cubano avanzando pensamos que
sobre su no estaría quizás el
expedientes alzheimer todo lo que lleva
las evaluaciones un inicio de
inoculaciones que permite empezar a
pensar en una vacunación masiva para
agosto confían en haber vacunado a 6
millones de personas más de la mitad de
la población de la isla caribeña una
estrategia que esperan que para final de
año llegue al total de la población y
después para el resto del mundo y que de
ahí en lo adelante se pueda seguir
trabajando en la fabricación
vacunas no solo para cuba sino también
para países que ya han mostrado
determinado interés a nuestros amigos
del 6 ver cuba tiene dos vacunas
candidatas en fase 3 soberana 2 y abdalá
se encuentran en una etapa de ensayos
clínicos que será combinada con estudios
de intervención con los que esperan
vacunar en mayo a 2 millones de personas
además están trabajando en otras tres
vacunas que están cerca de estar
finalizadas fruto del embargo que vive
la isla desde 1962 por parte de eeuu
cuba ha sido autosuficiente en la
producción de vacunas y el 80% de las
soluciones de su programa de
inmunización se producen localmente una
soberanía que llega a las vacunas contra
el cob y 19 idea y soberana el nombre de
dos de sus fármacos
y miren ustedes esta semana hubo
anuncios muy interesantes en eeuu en
medio de la controversia que dejó la
llegada masiva de turistas a la ciudad
de miami en el estado de florida en
donde se presentaron aglomeraciones
tiroteos peleas arrestos y desobediencia
por parte de los ciudadanos por ese
motivo las autoridades decretaron el
toque de queda en esta ciudad esto tuvo
lugar cuando también el país superó los
30 millones de casos de contagio pero el
gobierno se sigue mostrando muy confiado
en ese ritmo de vacunación por este
motivo el presidente joe biden indicó
que ya no serán 100 millones de
ciudadanos sino 200 millones de personas
800 millones de ciudadanos los que van a
ser vacunados en los primeros 100 días
de su gobierno qué tan factible sea
sobre todo cuando una buena parte de la
población tampoco confía en las vacunas
y no quiere ser vacunada le hacemos la
pregunta entonces a mamá en sala nuestra
corresponsal permanente en la ciudad de
nueva york
mamen ya lo decíamos 200 millones de
personas van a ser inmunizadas es la
ambición del presidente será fácil
alcanzar esa cifra contando los 40 días
que le quedan al presidente en este 1er
100 días de mandato
si el presidente de you wyden se propuso
administrar 100 millones de dosis contra
el cob y 19 sus 100 primeros días de
mandato ese objetivo se ha cumplido en
los primeros 58 días así que ahora el
presidente dobla el reto y dice que
quiere llegar a los 200 millones de
dosis administradas en sus 100 primeros
días de mandato que terminarían el 30 de
abril desde luego es una hazaña
ambiciosa pero no imposible bailén cree
que puede conseguirlo y a la vista de
los datos no resulta tan descabellado
porque en este momento se están
administrando en el país una media de 2
millones y medio de vacunas de manera
diaria hay más de 130 millones de dosis
administradas ya con 88 millones de
estadounidenses que han recibido al
menos una dosis y con más de 44 millones
de estadounidenses que están
completamente vacunados muy buenas
noticias que se espera además que este
ritmo de vacunación mejore en los
próximos días en los próximos
en muchos estados ya se está empezando a
vacunar a todo aquel adulto que lo
solicite el último estado en anunciar
esta iniciativa ha sido california que a
partir del 15 de abril comenzará a
vacunar a toda la población adulta que
quiera vacunarse también ya mencionaba
yo el caso de la ciudad de miami lo que
se ve allí fue un total descontrol por
parte de los ciudadanos violaciones a
todas las medidas de bioseguridad y
tuvieron que implementar medidas
extremas para evitar más contagios cómo
va la situación allí ahora que finaliza
la semana que han dicho y pues ya se
apaciguaran un poco los ánimos de los
turistas que llegaron allí
si el pasado fin de semana todos fuimos
testigos de esas imágenes
que parecían más bien de la época
prepandémica que no de la situación que
vivimos hasta ahora aglomeraciones de
personas una gran multitud algo que
obligó a la ciudad de miami a imponer un
toque de queda a partir de las 8 de la
noche en la zona de entretenimiento que
es donde sobre todo se aglutinan todos
los turistas y a ella establecer también
el estado de alerta en la ciudad del
estado de florida porque la situación
digamos se había completamente
descontrolado no bien este fin de semana
desgraciadamente todos miramos otra vez
a miami porque a la ola de turistas
continuó allí disfrutando de ese spring
break de ese descanso de primavera y se
teme que este fin de semana se vuelvan a
repetir las imágenes que ya vimos el fin
de semana pasado
de la ciudad asegura que se ha reforzado
el número de agentes para tratar que la
población no se aglutina y no se creen
grandes grupos además se ha establecido
un cierre de las calzadas a partir de
las 10 de la noche para evitar que mucha
gente camine por ellas y se va a tratar
de controlar en la medida de lo posible
esta situación dice el alcalde que esto
no es más que caos y desorden que pues
bueno procede de esos turistas que
llevan meses confinados o viviendo esta
pandemia y que están descargando toda su
tensión en miami algo que desde luego no
interesa a la ciudad sobre todo teniendo
en cuenta que el estado de florida sigue
ocupando el tercer puesto en cuanto a
los estados que recogen más contagios en
todo el país por detrás de california y
de texas bueno ya veremos qué tal el
comportamiento de estos turistas que
guarden la compostura este fin de semana
allí en la ciudad de miami porque además
de esta situación que se presentó en el
estado de la florida esta semana también
fue da a conocer una cifra que no es muy
alentadora mam en 30 millones de
personas contagiadas con kobe 19 en este
país que están haciendo muchísimos
esfuerzos para mitigar
impacto pero se siguen contagiando vemos
el caso de miami
si eeuu ha sumado más de 10 millones de
nuevos casos en tan solo los últimos
tres meses y ahora mismo superamos los
30 millones de contagiados en todo el
país con más de 547 mil fallecidos por
cubo y 19 la no tan mala noticia porque
desgraciadamente no es buena tampoco es
que lo que estamos viendo ahora mismo es
que la media de fallecimientos diarios
por kobe 19 está por debajo de las mil
personas unas cifras que no se veían
desde el pasado mes de noviembre la mala
noticia y esto preocupa mucho a los
expertos es que la población se estaría
relajando al positivismo debido al
positivismo traído por esa campaña de
vacunación que está teniendo tanto éxito
no solamente las personas también se
están relajando los estados muchos se
están levantando las restricciones y los
expertos advierten que
pues todavía puede llegar porque todavía
no tenemos esta pandemia controlada y se
teme mucho que haya otra hora de
contagios como la que está ocurriendo en
europa los expertos están también muy
preocupados por esas nuevas variantes
sobre todo la que primero se descubrió
en el reino unido porque muchos
advierten de que podría convertirse en
la variante predominante en eeuu a
finales de este mes o principios del que
viene también quiero retomar el tema de
la vacunación ya lo mencionaba 200
millones de personas para eso siempre
meros días de gobierno del presidente
baten es un esfuerzo enorme y el stock
de vacunas que tiene eeuu es envidiable
para muchos países en la comunidad
internacional pero hay muchos ciudadanos
que no confían en las vacunas que no
aceptan la existencia de la pandemia ni
el kobe 19 y que no se quieren vacunar
qué va a pasar entonces con estas
personas qué va a pasar con ese enorme
stock de vacunas que tiene disponible
este país
si hay algo de lo que se puede sentir
orgulloso este país es que el suministro
no está siendo un problema están
habiendo vacunas suficientes pero aquí
el problema cuando la mayoría de la
población e incluso 50% de la población
se vacune es otro y es convencer a los
ciudadanos de que las vacunas son
seguras según los últimos estudios que
se han hecho más del 54 por ciento de
los estadounidenses aseguraba que no se
iba a vacunar porque no lo acababa de
ver claro esto supone un problema
bastante importante a la hora de
conseguir esa inmunidad de rebaño es de
más de 70 por ciento de la población
vacunada que es digamos lo que
necesitaríamos para poder tener la
pandemia controlada y poder reabrir esa
economía eso es lo que han dicho los
expertos aquí así que cada vez son más
las empresas los anuncios y en general
pues por supuesto los estados y el país
sí o sí el gobierno en este país que
animan a la población a vacunarse que se
hacen campañas para promover esas
vacunas
los legisladores incluso le han pedido
al presidente you walden que obligue a
recibir la vacuna en el servicio militar
porque cada vez son más los que no
quieren vacunarse al servicio militar
ahora mismo tiene una tasa de rechazo de
la vacuna dentro del cuerpo de casi un
50% en muchas gracias por este completo
reporte del panorama en estados unidos y
ese foco en la ciudad de miami en el
estado de la florida ustedes muchas
gracias por su sintonía nos vemos la
próxima semana con otro resumen de los
hechos más destacados relacionados con
la pandemia kobe 19 en nuestro
continente sigan cuidándose el kobe 19
la emergencia persiste que se con
france24
[Música]